over the last few years
Apple has led its most popular laptop
the MacBook Air well deflate
then last week Apple decided to breathe
fresh air into its MacBook Air yes
that's a hot air balloon but stay with
me on this crazy ride for a moment after
not touching the laptops exterior or
screen for almost a decade it launched a
completely redesigned laptop yep
this thing this is the all-new MacBook
Air and well we're in the freaking air I
mention a fear of heights
Apple says a laptop is re-engineered
absolutely beautiful images are sharper
modern keyboard great twelve hours of
wireless web browsing the performance
you need for all of your everyday tasks
the question I came up here to ask is is
all that hot air short answer
not really
if you've had an old air the number one
reason to upgrade is the display the
laptop finally has a 13.3 inch Retina
screen that's four times the resolution
of the old one okay it's not as stunning
as this view but it's crisp and looks
great at all angles in my side-by-side
comparison the MacBook Pro screen was
only a tad brighter also gone from the
air is that big fat screen bezel bezel
was about the size of that at five acre
field right there that tiny screen frame
also gives the 2.7 pound laptop a
smaller footprint
I'd say it's lighter than air up here
but I'm actually petrified this will
drop gotcha
that didn't happen I miss the old airs
full size ports but these two USBC
Thunderbolt ports do everything from
charge the computer to connect to
multiple monitors often at the same time
[Music]
the keyboard has also been changed
though not necessarily for the better
the flatter Keys take some getting used
to
and even though apples made them quieter
they're still quite loud or at least
with my violent typing style it sounded
a keyboard bothering you not at all the
new fingerprint sensor at the top right
of the keyboard is faster than typing at
a password but why no face ID Apple no
complaints here on the trackpad though
it's big and responsive the main reason
I'd recommend you buy an air battery
life the airs Core i5 processor had more
than enough power for my usual workload
lots of browser tabs listening to music
light photo and video editing and
writing and it could take 11 1 hour hot
air balloon rides before needing to
charge the air just look down there at
the results of my battery life tests the
$1,300 MacBook lasted seven point five
hours the $1,300 entry-level MacBook Pro
10 hours the $1200 entry-level MacBook
Air 11 hours
that's impressive given the higher
resolution screen and thinner body but
not as good as the HP Spectre which
lasted 15 hours and just look at how
thin and sleek the HP is to look there
are issues Apple should have released
this laptop years ago the windows
competition has caught up and the
already high $1200 price tag is
misleading since you're probably gonna
want more than 128 gigabytes of storage
but I love this laptop just like I long
loved its predecessor there's no other
laptop I'd rather take a romantic
balloon ride with if you need more power
you should go up to the higher level
MacBook Pro but please don't buy that
smaller $1300 MacBook it's slow and
stupid bottom line is if you're up in
the air about what laptop to buy the
MacBook Air is probably the one I'm done
with the puns for now
can we can I do all my reviews on you
sure okay